how you doing mr. kid everyday you
trying to make me cry
Idid heard about what you did out there
he pulls through it's cuz of you Maggie
look back where's Paul it's been 15
months since you've been gone
that's a lifetime for a little kid hey
buddy it's me it's Bobby who's not my
mom
JC buddy he wants nothing to do with me
you just have to be patient sweetheart
were you patient no how does it feel
be back second time around it's always
an adjustment sir Yami's in Belleville
their hands
that's not tissues are you telling me
how to do my job we're gonna start over
okay my name's Maggie you like trucks
little truck big truck right there
looks like you there was your son yes
ready walk
some of the blue one nothing is trying
to our whoo cheers Cheers
I really listed why would you do that
because I'm good at my job
laughing we patrol and then you hear
this explosion but I just got word from
Italian they moved up deployment sir we
ship out 60 days so what so Afghanistan
I don't have a choice you had a choice
and you made it cuz you'll fight for
your country
but you won't fight for your son
sometimes I think power off if I hadn't
come back all I know is you're one out
why is it so hard for you to let down
your guard for a second did something
happen in back there we saw
a lot of things happen
you